[Musique]
au saut à tous bienvenue dans le grand
studio du figaro on est en direct on est
avec nous ses hauts revenus est avec
nous on est avec vous c'est figaro live
et on attend vos points de vue sur les
mesures prises notamment aux frontières
pour lutter contre la propagation du co
lead de lakovic 19 y croyez vous
croyez-vous à leur exécution nord débat
ce soir avec vous et avec alexandre de
make you bonsoir alexandre vous êtes
journaliste au figaro je cherche mes
mots mais non en fait ça je sais que
vous êtes au bureau et on sait que vous
êtes gervais yao en charge de figaro vox
et auteur de l'indispensable lecture de
ce début d'année recomposition le
nouveau monde populiste et c'est aux
éditions du cerf avec nous ce soir aussi
maxime desgagnés bonsoir maxime bon
alors je sais qu'on est important mais
je vous dis quand même bonne année et je
suis content de commencer ce ce début de
mois de février avec vous que frêche
anti expert à la fondation jean jaurès
et conseiller régional ps d'île de
france sur la liste d'andré plus voir
pour
lalor gélis n'ont pas encore totalement
bouclé mais en tout cas je suis à ses
côtés pour mener ce combat là
effectivement voilà comme ça on est
affûté et on est aux premières loges
pour être informé à des tractations qui
se passe donc au parti socialiste dans
la section ile de france maxime vous
êtes en pointe également sur twitter sur
le combat contre ce que vous appelez les
violences policières et on voir débattre
avec le démarrage effectif du beauvau de
la sécurité qu'en attendez-vous que
faut-il en attendre en attendez-vous
quelque chose eh bien on en débat ce
soir mais d'abord d'abord donc cette
question qu'on vous pose sur twitter est
ce que vous croyez aux contrôles aux
frontières
c'était il ya près d'un an c'était il ya
semble-t-il une autre vie emmanuel
macron ironisait le coronavirus ne
s'arrête pas aux frontières et depuis un
an deux confinement ont passé un
troisième pointe et quand jean castex a
fait cette déclaration tout entrer en
france et toute sortie de notre
territoire à destination ou en
provenance d'un pays extérieurs à
l'union européenne sera interdite sauf
motif 1 p
impérieux vous y croyez alexandre rioux
c'est déjà un progrès il a fallu un nom
pour que le bon sens triomphe enfin vous
l'avez rappelé d'abord oui olivero en
février qui au moment où une applique le
bon sens triomphe sg réplique non non et
non il y avait eu nanan ahoré le
changement va nous rappeler les
précédents 4 c'est à dire olivier
verrons qui en février au moment où
l'épidémie flambe en italie dès que de
fermer la frontière
ça n'aurait aucun sens et ensuite
effectivement emmanuel macron qui
expliquent le que le passeport
enfin que le passeport que le virus n'a
pas de passeport finalement il aura une
attestation et faute de fermer les
frontières mettra les gens enfermés dans
des frontières internes puisque
l'étymologie du mot confinement c'est le
mot frontières donc il ya un peu de
progrès mais je pense que le
gouvernement n'ira peut-être pas
jusqu'au bout de cette politique d abord
qui est fermé ce sont les frontières
extérieures à schengen
il s'agit pas de la frontière française
et ensuite je pense que la question des
frontières est un marqueur important
pour en marche
le maquereau nier c'est une posture
d'ouverture
c'est un européisme et s'il veut garder
distinction conserver une partie de
l'électorat de gauche qu'il faut qu'ils
conservent ce marqueur là donc il essaie
de faire du en même temps il parle de
souveraineté mais c'est de la
souveraineté européenne là il parle de
frontières mais le fait simplement à
l'échelle européenne et puis dans le
même temps gérald darmanin
tapez un grand coup contre génération
identitaire qui fait justement une
opération pour dénoncer le laxisme aux
frontières donc on voit bien que le le
virage je dirais souverainistes au
talent pour emmanuel macron n'est pas
possible sauf à se renier
idéologiquement complètement chardon
bleu dit sûr que je saluais de 10 sur le
site du figaro je pense que c'est ma
mesures arrivent trop tard est ce que
c'est votre avis maxime qu'elle soit en
contretemps certainement elle est
effectivement on peut pondre considérer
qu'elle arrive peut-être un peu tard
mais surtout je pense qu'il faut les
aborder sous un angle sanitaire avant
tout la question les sanitaires à l'est
pas je pense d'eux un positionnement
liée à la question du souverainisme à
l'ouverture des frontières au
cosmopolitisme c'est pas le sujet le
sujet c'est est ce que pensait que le
sujet est complètement absent de la
réflexion des manuels macron je pense en
tout cas que si on veut pouvoir répondre
la question c'est est ce qu'on croit à
la question de la fermeture ou en tout
cas de la restriction
de l'accès aux frontières du passage aux
frontières des annoncées par le
gouvernement je pense que pour pouvoir
répondre à la pandémie
je pense qu'il faut le voir sous un
angle sanitaires et pour le coup
j'aurais tendance à penser que je ne
crois pas que ça va permettre évidemment
de résoudre la pandémie parce que
à la limite on peut fermer les
frontières quand le virus n'était pas
encore présent il a pensé que y compris
les variants anglais et de variantes sud
africains seront présents sur le
territoire
donc on sait que ça de toute façon cette
mesure va être une mesure limitée ça
c'est le premier point le deuxième sujet
qui est posé sur cette mesure là c'est
qu' il serait bien qu'elle fasse qu'on
fasse preuve de cohérence voire
quelquefois d'anticipation et le sujet
principal c'est comment est-ce qu'on se
positionne aujourd'hui pour arriver à
obtenir une coordination européenne sur
le sujet puisque vous l'avez évoqué la
question aujourd'hui est posée c'est
évidemment l'espace européen et est ce
qu'il est nécessaire ou pas de faire
adopter des règles communes par
l'ensemble des pays parce qu'on peut se
rejoindre dans une situation où un nos
partenaires lui-même ne restreignent pas
comme d'ailleurs la france le faisait en
l'occurrence on était plutôt parmi les
mauvaises herbes ne restreignent pas
l'accès le l'accès à son territoire et
que par voie de conséquence ça a des
effets sur l'ensemble des européens
donc voilà donc pour moi le sujet doit
être vraiment pesé sous un angle
sanitaires et surtout doit être surtout
et bien complétée par d'autres mesures
alors juste avec 70 sont une réponse à
ce que dit maxime c'était une objection
plus que je voulais vous faire donc ça
tombe bien
maintenant que finalement le variant à
anglet circule énormément en france est
ce que pour reprendre la question de
chardons bleus pour reprendre
l'objection de maxime s'est pas trop
tard oui non mais c'est ce que je disais
mais mieux vaut tard que jamais et mieux
vaut effectivement l'intérieur donnait
pas parce qu'il peut y avoir d'autres
varions demain c'est pas la peine
d'accélérer la la circulation certes il
est présent mais peut-être qu'on peut
encore le contenir
si on ouvre les frontières et qu'il ya
encore d'autres variantes qui qui
arrivent notamment le brésilien qui je
crois est le plus
voilà celui là n'est pas le plus
agressif et qui est ne me sens pas
encore sur le territoire on ne fera
qu'aggraver la situation donc il me
semble logique de de fermer les
frontières les pays qui ont mieux
résisté sont des pays plutôt fermé le
japon la nouvelle-zélande la corée du
sud notamment alors on peut
effectivement l'appréhender que d'un
point de vue sanitaire d'ailleurs ça
aurait été habile à emmanuel macron sans
se renier de l'aborder simplement du
point de vue sanitaire dont on voit bien
que l'idéologie a pesé parce que je
pense que si il a tant tardé c'est parce
que justement pour v c'était un marqueur
idéologique dont il ne voulait pas se
départir et vous l'avez dit oh jusqu'au
bout aura été les mauvais élèves
justement parce que les manuels ma peau
où elle voulait incarner l'europe
ouverte même en période de pandémie
sylvie nous dit sur youtube c'est un
confinement dur qu'il fallait comme en
mars avril 2020 est ce que c'est votre
point de vue aussi maxi c'est plutôt mon
point de vue enfin tabor tout le monde a
un point de vue ça c'est vrai il n'ya
pas de façon de 6 millions de procureurs
parc notre dame
interfel est assez durement sur ces
questions valérie pécresse au conseil
régional d'île de france on peut le voir
sur twitter
on peut imaginer que vous avez à prendre
juste j'ai un point de vue et comme donc
comme beaucoup donc je ne dis pas que il
est meilleur que d'autres mais en tout
cas moi je souffre qu'on n'est pas
aujourd'hui de véritables stratégies je
prends un exemple puisqu'il vient d'être
annoncé qu'il y allait avoir un nouveau
conseil de défense mercredi
c'est par exemple la question des
vacances c'est à dire qu' une partie des
français vont se retrouver dès vendredi
en congés scolaires
on est aujourd'hui dans une position
d'attenté en réalité puisque le
gouvernement a décalé la question du
confinement considérant qu'ils aient pas
besoin de l'engager dès vendredi dernier
que va-t-il se passer pour les gens qui
se retrouvent face à des congés et ce
qu'ils ont la possibilité de se déplacer
pas de se déplacer ce que ça veut dire
qu'il aura des mesures restrictives qui
vont arriver en plein coeur des vacances
on revient les difficultés que ça peut
poser en termes de déplacements et donc
moi je crois que d'abord il est toujours
mieux de faire un confinement en
commençant plus bas possible pour
pouvoir en sortir le plus vite possible
donc je il me semble et moi que au
regard de ce que disent elles en zone en
préventif
quand confinement préventif ces
histoires un confinement qui s'articule
avec d'autres choses et à dire que
penser un confinement aujourd'hui dans
un moment où on sait que le temps est
mauvais ou on sait qu'on n'a pas assez
de vaccins pour pouvoir essayer de
reprendre un peu la main sur la gestion
de la pandémie pour qu'en mars avril on
se retrouve dans une situation où
potentiellement il ya plus de gens qui
soient vaccinés où on puisse commencer à
faire un déconfinement par paliers qui
permettent par exemple dans les écoles
de pouvoir plus facilement ouvrir les
fenêtres commencé à ouvrir toute une
série de services
moi ça m'aurait semblé opportun alors
vous me dites vous me direz on ne sait
pas où on va donc il ya des incertitudes
donc c'est compliqué de construire des
stratégies de moyen terme
mais je pense que le gouvernement comme
depuis longtemps fait une erreur qui est
pas suffisamment vue c'est qu'il ne
compile ne perçoit pas l'opinion des
gens il a peur aujourd'hui des de la
contestation de ce qui se passe au pays
bas des appels à ne pas respecter les
règles moi il me semble que ce don ce
qui aujourd'hui pénalise les gens ce
n'est pas les règles c'est les
incertitudes géré demain si vous dites
au français bah écoutez on vous confirme
quatre mois et puis après c'est terminé
tout le monde signe le sujet c'est
l'incertitude et l'absence de
perspectives du gouvernement qui
n'assument pas qui n'assume pas ses
responsabilités dans ce domaine
à mon avis est fautif alexandre sur ce
que vient me dire maxime est ce que vous
pensez vous aussi que le gouvernement
fait une erreur d'analystes le
gouvernement n'appréhende pas séduit
l'opinion des gens que par exemple le
l'opinion publique serait favorable à un
confinement pourvu qu'on donne une date
de fin un tout est dans le pur view
condamné une date de fin est dedans
pourvu qu'on ait les moyens logistiques
alors que ce soit une date de fin mai
une date de sortie de crise également
donc effectivement un confinement dur
aurait du sens si on était capable de
d'époux déployer une stratégie de
vaccination massive par exemple comme
c'était le cas en israël où le plus la
moitié de la population est vaccinée ou
effectivement l'épidémie diminue le
problème c'est que je ne crois pas que
nous soyons en mesure de déployer cette
stratégie là et que si on confinait
maintenant ce sera probablement un
confinement très long
sans perspective de sortie de crise
notamment il y avait un confinement à
rebondissements un petit peu alors oui
ou alors ont été brisées ou alors
arrêtez de l'espoir parce que moi je
peux aussi dire que les deux premiers
confinement étaient en fait des échecs
on nous a dit que c'était des réussites
mais c'est des échecs dans le sens où il
ou ils n'ont pas stopper l'épidémie
contrairement à ce qu'on nous a dit nous
ont perdu permis de réduire
effectivement l'embouteillage à à
l'hôpital on pouvait se dire qu'après le
confinement
on allait augmenter les capacités
d'accueil justement pour éviter le
scénario d'un deuxième continent rien
n'est fait entre chaque confinement donc
ça peut continuer l'otan donc maintenant
je pense qu'on peut se laisser peut-être
jusqu'à l'été pour voir si on arrive en
six mois déployer une stratégie
vaccinale mais si on n'y arrive pas il
va peut-être falloir vivre avec
avec ce virus est la question qui se
posera c est ce que oui ou non je
continuais à vivre ou pas sous cloche
pas bon si vous permettez à l'orge un
jet un point d'accord avec vous sur le
fait que effectivement aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas de stratégie
global donc c'est quelque chose de
difficile et qu'on vous dit que entre
les confinements on à pas menus prix ont
pris en main finalement on n'a pas pris
les mesures nécessaires je peux être
d'accord avec vous on l'a vu sur la
question des lycées des universités où
on savait durant l'été qui fait faire
des travaux notamment pour les cantines
scolaires et ils n'ont pas été engagées
dans toutes les régions y compris en
région ile de france
donc on arrive on n'arrive pas à
lesparre exécutif dildo ne penserait
première vue d'anticiper tout ça après
la oumma moi il me semble qui je mise
nord palais des impacts économiques et
sociaux psychologiques aujourd'hui du
confinement mais je crois que la façon
dont gouvernement navigue à vue et
change toutes les semaines de règles est
aussi quelque chose qui n'est pas
forcément très positif
on parle de la lassitude des français
qu'on vit tous sur le couvre-feu mais
moi j'ai aussi la lassitude des mesures
qui change de semaine en semaine et qui
nous permettent pas d'avoir un minimum
de 20 loges de gouvernement mais c'est
une stratégie du pauvre dicté par la
gale l'impréparation et la capacité
justement de déployer une stratégie
globale
j'ai pas compris tout à leur maximum
pour revenir au thème de cette partie si
le excuses avait une objection de
principe à ce que on ferme les
frontières pour éviter la propagation
d'un virus ou pas alors d'abord c'est le
sien non pas sur lèze parce qu'on n'est
pas sûr d'ailleurs une fermeture parce
qu'il ya encore pour motiver la première
rétablissement des frontières
donc moi je n'ai pas de problème comme
d'ailleurs au passage moi je fais partie
des gens qui n'ont pas de difficultés si
on permet d'aller jusqu'au bout de ma
phrase sur la question d'un passeport de
vaccination parce que ça existe
il ya des pays dans lequel est
d'ailleurs moi qui suis hyper de jeunes
enfants
quand vous avez quand vous mettez votre
enfant à l'école il faut que vous soyez
à jour de vaccination
donc moi je n'ai pas de problème pour
que ces questions sanitaires soient
quelquefois des questions qui permettent
de d'être pris en compte pour accéder
que ce soit d'ailleurs à l'école que
cela soit pour pouvoir entrer sur un
territoire
dès lors je parle de la vaccination dès
lors que tout le monde peut se faire
vacciner parce que c'est évidemment le
problème on peut pas demander à des gens
aujourd'hui deux évidemment être
vaccinés s'ils n'ont pas la capacité de
pouvoir le faire
donc moi je n'ai pas de problème de
principe par rapport à ça on vit une
situation exceptionnelle
la question c'est qu'il faut que tout ça
soit raisonnée etc et je parlais tout à
l'heure de la question de la
coordination européenne
je voyais depuis 24 heures et depuis ces
nouvelles mesures les difficultés qui
avait aujourd'hui les douaniers et les
services publics à faire accepter ce
type de ce type de mesure et ce contrôle
là donc on peut décider de quelque chose
mais si derrière mais pas les moyens
c'est compliqué et puis si vous me
permettez de dire quelque chose en plus
avait que l'on vous a laissé finir notre
frais et c'est pour ça que j'ai ici on a
toujours très respectueux des gens qui
interviennent même des bavards juste un
dernier point est en le prenant dans
notre pays c'est la question de du
télétravail puisque le télétravail a
perdu 10 points depuis quelques mois
c'est la question que j'ai évoquées qui
va être les prochaines vacances
scolaires et donc potentialités
population ces questions le jour où
djoko joue comme nicole juste envie je
sens venir une interdiction de
déplacement avant les vacances de
février
je me permets juste quand même jeu
puisque c'est quand même le thème est le
thème de cette partie c'est sur les
frontières si il y à des restrictions
qui sont données à l'intérieur de
l'union européenne
c'est par exemple sion ont restreint
l'entrée de certains ressortissants de
l'union européenne
vous avez une objection de principe ou
parce je voulais dire aujourd'hui
pourquoi est-ce qu'on fait ça c'est pas
pour des questions dogmatiques et
j'entends que aujourd'hui elles prennent
le passé par
sur la question de l'ouverture la
souveraineté c'est pour des questions
sanitaires c'est un sujet d'interactions
sociales
il faut limiter les interactions
sociales si on prend ce prisme là la
question c'est qu'il faut que les gens
se voient moins donc il faut qu'ils
aient du télétravail
il faut que les gens se déplacent en moi
et dans quel cadre là moi j'ai pas de
problème d'accord non je vous posais
cette question parce que j'ai entendu
olivier faure sur sur europe 1 ce
week-end dire qu'il était favorable à un
confinement différencier d'une région à
l'autre donc c'était pour ça que je veux
savoir si si c'était vous voyez ce n'est
pas comme en face absolument une réponse
peut-être un domaine voilà on est
d'accord si ce n'est que de l'idéologie
là dessus et tant mieux si on est
pragmatique mais sur la question de
l'immigration au moment de la vague
migratoire
ceux qui pensent que est nécessaire
d'avoir une frontière ne sont pas et de
la contrôler ne sont pas forcément sur
des positions dogmatiques c'est aussi
une forme de pragmatisme parce que on
peut considérer que des flux
d'immigration trop concentré pose des
problèmes d'intégration et que de
manière pragmatique sa sacrée de la
crise à l'intérieur de la de la société
française donc la logique à mon avis des
frontières se tient de manière générale
et là où ça va être compliqué pour ceux
qui ne ne voulait pas de leur contrôle
c'est que dans cette crise on voit bien
que que mécaniquement les solutions à un
peu souverainiste apparaissent comme des
solutions de bon sens y compris sur le
plan économique les a révélé notre
immense dépendance à l'égard de la chine
notamment sur le plan industriel
si vous permettez je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les flux qui sont visés
par des interdictions de frontières sont
principalement des flux touristiques
parce que c'est quand même ça
aujourd'hui qui fait la majorité des
flux notamment en france les français
vont à l'étranger ils l'ont fait
d'ailleurs ces dernières semaines quand
il le pouvait pour essayer de retrouver
de trouver un peu de soleil quelques
fois où d'autres choses que fonds
permettrait de penser donc nous ne
sommes pas d'accord là dessus comme quoi
on est capable quelquefois de pouvoir
avoir le même avis sur une mesure mais
on va dire avec un raisonnement qui est
totalement inversée et
je suis d'accord les différents noms et
je suis d'accord que là on le ferme pour
des raisons sanitaires je dis simplement
on a beaucoup tardé à le faire pour des
raisons idéologiques et qu' il
m'apparaît pas dogmatique de vouloir des
frontières y compris pour d'autres
questions que la question sanitaire
je donne la parole aux internautes
dix cols dont on disait c'est au
printemps dernier qu'il aurait fallu
fermer
jean-louis nous dit sur youtube on ne
peuvent pas parler de frontières dans ce
débat si on parle de frontières de
l'union européenne qui sont vraiment
trop peureuse et trop difficile à rendre
vraiment étanche est bénigne au nous dit
tout et décide et non pas en pensant en
france et aux entreprises à de santé
mais à la prochaine élection
présidentielle une question subsidiaire
juste pour avoir une réponse courte qui
est connexe
est-ce qu'il fallait sanctionner les
restaurateurs comme l'a annoncé bruno le
maire aussi durement en supprimant les
aides pour un mois ou pouvoir
définitivement s'il ya si elle récidive
alexandre le gouvernement à un moment où
bravent l'interdît le gouvernement à
partir du moment où ils où le maintien
ce confinement est obligé de faire
respecter et de faire respecter les
règles après moi ma sympathie va plutôt
du côté des restaurateurs je me mets à
la place du gouvernement mais je me mets
à plat la place aussi de ceux qui jouent
leur survie et si gesterra lgt
restaurateurs et que je devais me
nourrir ma famille sans doute brave rage
les interdictions après il ya la
question de la désobéissance civile qui
se pose c'est une vaste question en
démocratie puisque la démocratie c'est
la loi de la majorité sur la majorité
doit l'emporter sur la minorité mais
enfin démocratie il ya aussi des droits
des droits fondamentaux et d'ailleurs il
est paradoxal dans cette crise de ceux
qui sont pour l'extension à l'infini des
noix fondamentaux habituellement piétine
des droits élémentaires qui sont dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et
dans la constitution depuis toujours
alors on peut admettre que ces droits
soient piétinées pendant un temps
d'exception
une loi d'exception mais là ça commence
à faire longtemps et la question qui
commence à se poser est ce que c'est ça
va être pérenne et dans ce cas là nous
ne saurions plus en démocratie
voilà aussi je vais prendre le point de
vue des restaurateurs mais de ceux qui
respectent depuis le début
les nouvelles règles qui sont largement
imposés et précisément au nom de cela je
pense que c'est bien de sanctionner
fortement ceux qui ne respectent pas ce
que les autres respectent
est ce que vous êtes d'accord justement
avec nos débatteurs veut encore nous le
dire on y reviendra en la fin de la
deuxième partie que nous allons aborder
en attendant je vous pose on vous poser
une question sur sur twitter et la
question étant la suivante la
restriction des voyages à l'étranger des
contrôles aux frontières seront
inefficaces face aux convives 10,9 et
vous répondez à une petite majorité 56%
vous répondez oui le sur l'autre
question qu'on pose sur twitter vous est
beaucoup plus catégorique
la question qu'on pose c'est si vous
attendez quelque chose du beauvau de la
sécurité alors ça vous a peut être
échappé mais c'est ce matin qu'a été
officiellement lancé ce effectivement
lancée en tout cas ce beauvau de la
sécurité et au micro on retrouve encore
jean castex et une annonce une loi de
programmation sur la sécurité interne
hier intérieur pardon et sur les forces
de sécurité elles ont tout mon soutien
et je le dis mon plus profond respect il
le serait dur s en aller autrement dans
il est fondamental que les rapports la
police et de la gendarmerie avec la
population soit des rapports de
confiance usage de la force
lorsqu'elle est nécessaire doit être
compris comme légitime par l'ensemble
des concitoyens c'est le seul moyen pour
qu'elle soit acceptée et respectée
voilà pourquoi nous ne saurions tolérer
que des pratiques inadmissibles puissent
venir entacher l'exercice de cette
mission principe hier alors
qu'attendez-vous de ce bourg de la
sécurité on attend dé vous quelque chose
c'est des questions qu'on pose sur
twitter et voici avant de regarder les
réponses avant de débattre avec vous et
bien la réponse l'espoir d'un
syndicaliste policier de l'unsa police
oui plusieurs chantiers qui sont figurés
terrain notamment le
rapport entre la population et la police
c'est un des sujets phare du nouveau de
la sécurité où on aura des propositions
concrètes à faire au ministre par
rapport à ses relations là il est
important de recréer du lien entre les
policiers et la population et le bouvau
de la sécurité sera un des outils pour
essayer d'y parvenir
on sera à quelques mois des échéances
présidentielles est évidemment une des
inquiétudes qu'on peut avoir c'est que
c'est que ce chantier là soit détournée
par la classe politique pour en faire
pour en faire un sujet et de pré
campagne présidentielle
alors maxime des gayets ce que vous
attendez quelque chose de ce bureau de
la sécurité bien vous pensez comme
nicole que c'est encore un comité pour
noyer le poisson
c'est l'avenir qui va nous le dire
j'attends un point de vue alors plus
sérieusement on peut en oui j'en attends
beaucoup de choses parce que la
situation aujourd'hui
de la pluie c'est compliqué à la fois
les conditions d'exercice des policiers
et puis surtout puisque c'est de là que
ce bobo est partie la dégradation
puissante du lien entre la police et les
citoyens y avait une étude du cevipof
qui montrait très clairement que la
confiance envers
la pokal cool que les français ont
envers la police a a diminué en france
aujourd'hui on est un des pays d'europe
où les gens moins confiance en la police
est donc a nécessité la police quand le
journaliste un moment où il ya plus de
confiance dans la police que dans les
médias oui mais c'est vrai mais ça a de
toute façon vous êtes souvent en queue
de peloton donc mais les resteraient
politiquement sont encore derrière vous
donc à devoir des banquiers voilà non
mais non mais sérieusement c'est c'est
une question extrêmement important c'est
ce beauvau il fait suite à ces à des
épisodes de violences policières qui ont
évidemment leur thé massivement
l'opinion publique qui nécessitent des
réponses fortes et donc moi j' attends
beaucoup de choses à la fois sur la
formation des policiers
et puis j'allais dire j'aimerais espérer
une chose c'est que il ya un peu de
cohérence alors je sais que je suis un
peut-être un peu naïf en ce début
d'année mais on dit que c'est
généralement les bonnes résolutions dont
j'attendais tout à l'heure de la
stratégie du gouvernement sous le co
village attend de la cohérence du
gouvernement sur la question de la
police
ça fait beaucoup
mais parce que pourquoi je parle de
cohérence parce que il ya bien souvent
des coups de menton contradictoires qui
met en contradiction les décisions
gouvernementales
et puis vous l'avez vu là encore même
ceux beauvau commence déjà à être pollué
par la loi sur la sécurité globale et
donc moi j'aimerais qu'il ya un vrai
temps de discussions d'échangés de
décision avec cette initiative
alexandre est ce que vous attendez
quelque chose de ce beau de la sexualité
est ce qu'il faut en attendre quelque
chose de ce qui remonte des
contributions à figure alors là la
préoccupation sécuritaire à une réelle
pro qui pré occupations dans le pays
depuis longtemps mais je trouve qu'il
est un peu tard dans le quinquennat pour
pour y venir
ce gouvernement ne vous dit pas mieux
vaut tard que jamais non parce que a
priori ce gouvernement n'est plus en
place pour très longtemps donc on va
faire un grand raout et qui va appliquer
les mesures on sait pas très bien parce
que voilà la démocratie peut faire que
ce gouvernement sera soit renvoyée soit
renvoyée à la maison tout ça sous fond
de crise sociale et économique qui va se
précipiter l'autre où on consomme on
sent bien que les budgets risque d'être
remis en cause donc je pense que là on a
un gigantesque écran de fumée si je veux
l'être totalement cynique alors il n'a
pas été décidé pour ça mais je pense
qu'il va être pratique ce mot de la
sécurité pour le gouvernement puisque en
période de confinement et de tension il
va falloir s'appuyer sur des forces de
l'ordre qui ces derniers temps ont
plutôt renâclé moi je trouve que c'était
plutôt à le rhône honneur elle considère
qu'ils avaient mieux à faire que de
mettre des amendes aux citoyens et
d'aller faire la chasse aux
restaurateurs
on voit les consignes de la préfecture
là depuis ce ce week-end qui se
durcissent et on peut se demander s'il
va pas y avoir des concessions de fait
d'ailleurs légitimes sur les salaires ou
souvient au moment dé gilet jaune
on avait commencé un peu à payer les
heures supplémentaires
a promis ce matin plus d'effectifs une
amélioration de la qualité de la
rapidité de la chaîne pénale
cela va dans le mur oui donc tant mieux
pour les policiers c'est légitime mais
voilà ça j'ai peur que ce soit
simplement pour pour s'appuyer sur la
police à un moment où le le gouvernement
risque d'être en difficulté avec son
peuple
maxime d'égailler vous avez saisi le
procureur de paris après les vidéos de
l'interpellation de producteur de rap
michel est clair quand jean castex
promet des débats en toute lucidité et
sans arrière-pensées sur ces violences
ça ne vous convient pas si parce que bon
vous laisse vous dit j'attends de voir
je sais c'est quelque chose de très
inquiétant le délitement de ce lien
entre aides soleil confiance entre la
police et les citoyens c'est pas
seulement gers et c'est chaque fois que
j'aborde cette question s'est il s'agit
pas de se mettre du côté seulement des
victimes même s'il faut toujours le
faire mais c'est aussi de pouvoir
interpeller l'état et la police sur les
conséquences d'une délégitimation
finalement de des activités policières
ça c'est très préoccupant pour pour gers
est pas un problème de police
c'est un problème républicain et donc
moi j'attends qu'ils aient des réponses
fortes là dessus elles peuvent être de
quel ordre il faut qu'ils aient décision
symbolique c'est sûr il ya la question
de l'igpn et de sa réforme qui est une
question quand même qui est lancinante
depuis de nombreuses années et donc
j'espère qu'il y aura des décisions
fortes qui vont être opérés en ce sens
et puis vous avez des questions plus
lourdes alors j'avoue qui comme vous le
dites qui arrivent tardivement qu'ils
sont contradictoires avec ce qu'a fait
ce gouvernement est là dessus je vous
rejoindrai pour dénoncer ces agissements
mais voyez par exemple sur la question
des formations d mais depuis juin
depuis donc ses gouvernants depuis juin
la formation était réduite de douze à
huit mois donc ce j'imagine que ce
beauvau devrait mettre l'accent sur le
fait que huit mois ne suffisent pas pour
former un policier donc on va revenir
j'espère d'ailleurs à une forme à une
formation un peu plus lourde
donc vous voyez bien que ça ses seins
c'est un chantier important et là où je
dis qu'il ya des sujets quelquefois qui
sont des sujets lourds moi je pense
notamment aux policiers c'est que sur
des questions de recrutement notamment
vous avez évoqué le fait que le
gouvernement a annoncé faire des
recrutements il va faire des
recrutements c'est dans le son budget au
passage pour l'instant et de l'effet en
prenant l'argent sur l'investissement
sur le fonctionnement puisque
l'investissement du fonctionnement de la
police nationale vont baisser de 13 et
14% cette année pour pouvoir financer
les 2000 postes supplémentaires de
policiers donc on va dégrader les
conditions d'exercice des policiers pour
faire des recrutements je suis favorable
au recrutement
mais il voit qu'il ya un effort qu'il
soit global et surtout et surtout
aujourd'hui les 75% des policiers qui
sont recrutés en province est
généralement
une grande part à peu près l'équivalent
sert trois quarts d'entre eux sont
affectés dans des territoires compliqué
en ile de france
est ce que c'est le meilleur moyen et
qu'est ce que vous en voyez dans ces
territoires
vous pouvez imaginer aujourd'hui dans un
vrai sujet de recrutement qui est lié
d'ailleurs aux conditions d'exercice des
policiers serre que c'est pas toujours
un travail attractif donc un vrai il ya
une vraie stratégie à penser sur ce soit
sur ce sur ce terrain là il ya peu de
candidats aujourd'hui voilà et pourquoi
parce que l'image de la police a dégradé
on peut envoyer dans les territoires les
plus compliqués les gens les plus
expérimentés parce que c'est je retrouve
objectivement dangereux pour la police
pour les citoyens pour tout le monde que
d'envoyer des gens qui sont pas
expérimenté dans des territoires
compliqué là c'est des choses concrètes
qui je l'espère seront réglés parce
qu'au bout il ya des images qu'on on a
montré qu'ils étaient les images de
l'interpellation de michel est clair il
ya d'autres images celles qu'on a vu
encore ce week end qu on va voir dans un
instant qui on voit effectivement des
manifestants encore s'en prendre à des
policiers délibérément on connaît ces
groupes on les a identifiés qui font
justement profession de provoquer
justement une réplique est une réplique
c'est que répressive de la part des
policiers c'est le fameux cycle
provocation répression est ce que vous
comprenez pas que justement quand on
voit ces images
et quant au menton finalement assez peu
de condamnations de ces agissements
là la vocation vis-à-vis de la potion de
policiers diminuent alors moi je ne
pense pas qu'il y ait pas de
condamnation malheureusement on a vécu
des épisodes de violences majeures
contre les forces de police ces
dernières années ces derniers mois et
[Musique]
évidemment on était totalement en
soutien des forces de police face à des
agressions qui
[Musique]
non son sont inexcusables après délibéré
délibéré oui je suis d'accord les
organiser et penser je vous dis je vous
dis pas mais ça ne justifie en rien
enfin gers est l'exemple à rater
l'exemplarité qui a attendu des forces
de police je dirais les forces de police
c'est un uniforme
vous représentez l'état et la puissance
police était le sens de ma question
c'est est ce que vous ne pensez
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que là il
ya un élément d'explication
justement dans la baisse des vocations
jeu on peut le parce que parce que ça
sert métiers peuvent pas ça pas
seulement faire quand les policiers sont
attaqués et ils ont été ils ont été la
cible d'attentats
évidemment que le danger d de l'exercice
même d'être policier et bien
est mise en avant et je veux bien croire
que on voit évidemment tous tous les
enjeux et toutes les difficultés de
rentrer dans cette vocation là donc pour
moi c'est ça mais je pense que le
problème de la faim pour répondre à
votre question ce qui est aujourd'hui
réduit la vocation de certains citoyens
à faire le travail de policier c'est
leurs mauvaises conditions d'exercice
parce qu'aujourd'hui ils sont dans des
îles ont peu de matériel on sait vous
aviez des pleins de d'études de
reportages où on voit les des conditions
objectivement difficile dans lequel les
policiers exercent leur métier
et la deuxième chose c'est qu'il ya un
lien qui s'était distendu de confiance
entre les six entre la république les
citoyens et la police y est ce qu'il
n'ya pas un autre problème c'est ce que
nous dit élan le problème ce sont les
juges rouges dont on sait que
c'est une expression les policiers
s'épuisent pour rien et c'est la chaîne
pénale nodyna rend le problème quelle
est la crédibilité d'un policier qui
retrouve un art une personne qui l'a
arrêté il ya quatre heures oui c'est une
certitude qu'il faut qu'il ait une
réforme globale de toute la chaîne
pénale est alors il ya un bout la
sécurité mais pourra y avoir un grenelle
effectivement de la justice rendra à
vendôme de la justice mais ce qui va
être compliqué parce qu'on a compris que
le garde des sceaux était pas forcément
sur la même ligne que le ministre de
l'intérieur là encore on touche aux
limites du en même temps ensuite je
rejoins moi ce qui a été dit en partie
c'est à dire que je crois que cette
crise d'ailleurs de sanitaire met au
jour la défaillance profonde d'un état
bureaucratique obèses mais en même temps
le besoin d'un état régalien vous dans
les services utiles j'ai parlé tout à
l'heure des lits d'hôpitaux ou tôt c'est
pareil dans la plaie je pense qu'il ya
besoin de davantage d'effectifs que la
réforme des rg pp engagé par la droite
d'ailleurs a été une catastrophe
davantage d'effectifs mieux préparer
mieux payés mieux formés donc ça c'est
une c'est une certitude mais je ne crois
pas qu'on va aller vers ça je crois
qu'on va caresser l'a vu le temps qui
reste à cette majorité les policiers
dans le sens du poil pour permettre de
passer au mieux le confinement et ça ça
risque encore de distendre justement la
relation entre les citoyens et les
policiers parce qu'un relation est
mauvaise pas tant sur la question des
violences policières qu'il faut bien
bien sûr condamné mais je crois pas du
tout qu'elle soit systémique mais aussi
soir un sentiment de deux poids deux
mesures d'une police qui a parfois été
extrêmement durs on l'a vu avec les
gilet jaune qui est dur quand il s'agit
de mettre des amendes etc et qui assez
impuissant sur le stream se trompe à
doral des territoires perdus de la
république sur le goût des gauchistes
d'alexandre alexandre justement est-ce
que sur cette question des amendes par
exemple ne fasse deux pays sont pas
soutenues sont soutenus regarder
couvre-feu approuvez-vous le
renforcement des contrôles de la police
la question qui est posée sur le site du
figaro
aujourd'hui et 66% des personnes qui
répondent on est quasiment à 100 mille
réponses répondent oui alors c'est pas
un sondage dans tous les cas il ya un
sentiment profond que finalement sur cet
aspect on parle électeurs des
restaurants il ya un soutien
je pense qu'il ya un profond besoin
d'ordre dans le pays et d'autorité qui
datent pas d'aujourd'hui et c'est vrai
que la crise sanitaire fait que certains
ils voient l'occasion de d'établir une
forme de deux par deux parties de
l'ordre mais moi je pense que je crois
plus à l'ordre juste et je crois que ce
qui pèse beaucoup plus sur le pays c'est
les désordres structurels qu'on connaît
depuis longtemps
plutôt que les petites infractions qu'on
filme on a vu que les français elle
était plutôt raisonnable et passion dans
cette crise maxime
un dernier point vous êtes moins
pessimiste que alexandre sur ce beau de
la sécurité vous en attendez un petit
peu plus
nous on va vous m'avez demandé ils en
attendaient quelque chose que j'ai dit
oui parce que je voulais mettre en avant
le fait que c'est un grand chantier et
on est d'accord pour considérer d'accord
voilà après la désaffection vous pouvez
la reformuler de cette façon c'est ce
que vous attendez ces choses de ce
gouvernement dans le bon sens si ce
n'est pas le sens et la question merci
doit pas non mais oui je non mais j'en
attend quelque chose j'ose espérer ont
ils des buts
voilà il me demande est venue ainsi
qu'alexandre sur cette question de la
programmation il ya huit chantiers qui
ont été posées sur la question de la
formation je pense qu'il ya matière à
pouvoir j'espère engager des réformes
sur la question du lien entre
du entre les citoyens à la police il ya
beaucoup de choses à faire j'espère que
ça ne sera pas une opération de
communication est bien en tous les cas
les internautes qui se sont prononcés
qui ont répondu à la question sur
twitter sont eux beaucoup moins
enfin anthony qui a eu honte rencontre h
30 chez et non pas tellement d'espérance
puisque 85% vous n'aurez ils disent
qu'ils n'attendaient rien du haut-anjou
qu ils n'attendent pas quelque chose du
beauvau de la sécurité merci beaucoup de
nous avoir répondu alors jeu comme
promis justement il y avait un
internaute qui revenait sur la question
des restaurants ses élans qui dit je ne
comprends pas qu'on ait fermé les restos
les restaurants qui prenait les bonnes
précautions mais ça pourrait être
également un autre sujet de débat on
vous retrouve en tous les cas demain
même heure même endroit à partir de 17h
on essaiera de tenir les temps merci
beaucoup de nous avoir suivis en tous
les cas ce soir audition publique est
l'invité ce n'est pas olivier à grégoire
d' comment on avait annoncé dans un
premier temps mais ce sera damien abad
président du groupe
lr à l'assemblée nationale et donc
j'irai poser vos questions en fin
d'émission à très vite sur figaro live
merci merci d'avoir été là merci à vous
ainsi
[Musique]